[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
it's another week in fortnite and things
are moving forward
i've got 20 changes for you this time if
you're new around these parts this
is the series in which we hunt down the
secrets on fortnite battle royale island
subscribe to keep the series going it's
totally free
and think about using code adamaru in
the store to join the legends roll call
fortnite chapter two season three week
six
let's do this hot watch like i was gonna
start anywhere else other than this good
looking specimen
here's how it looks today the building
continues to grow and more chairs fill
up the place
the hut watch habitat poi is evolving
the wood inside is now a darker shade
indicating we may get a change of color
next update
by the way if we get 69 000 likes i'll
finally get round to commissioning a hut
watch forever t-shirt
nobody wants one of those do they it's
been over a year since we started
watching hot watch when it was rebuilt
back in chapter 1 and just as it was
finished
the black hole sucked us all into
another dimension
then a humongous eight months ago the
chair truck and pallet trucks began to
travel slowly towards each other
we watched them for weeks and months
until they finally collided
and then hut watch chapter 2 was found
and began to grow so treasure those
memories because it's taken a long time
to get here
whilst finding footage of hot watch from
chapter one i actually found the first
time i mentioned hut watch
little did i know what this would become
another tiny change which could grow
into something is the hut
above the farm it was destroyed by kevin
all those seasons back but now
has begun the repair process let's see
what happens next i won't lie
that really hit me in the fields don't
cry
by the way the nearby wagons and trucks
have all vanished right now this could
be for two reasons
maybe they've finished or maybe it's the
vehicle update that we're still waiting
for
right now this is the only vehicle to
survive
so the lack of cars many of us were
waiting for this day
and the introduction of cars in fortnite
from the looks of it
they aren't ready just yet and epic are
putting the final touches in place
over the next day or two the strangest
phenomenon is though is that all cars
are now missing on the map they've gone
completely vanished nowhere in sight the
strangest place to see this right now
is risky reels it's mind-blowing how
empty it feels without those static
cars will they ever return and will all
cars be drivable or just a few
we'll have to wait and see later this
week oh by the way
check out what the removal of vehicles
has done to truckasaurus himself
he is now headless he's been through so
much this chap he lost an arm in chapter
one
and now this this hero deserves better
please rescue him epic game developer
watching right now
you have the power not all superheroes
wear capes
and hey segway truckasaurus is arch
enemy
the bog warrior on the opposite side of
the map last week he rose out of the
water like a majestic dolphin
and i asked you to name him you did in
your hundreds
some great names popped up like the
porta potty patroller
damn good and the flush fighter another
great one
and even more names were suggested which
i can't say on youtube but i laughed
anyway
if you're following me on twitter you
already know the name of this beast
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
splashback spartan
ready to take anything you throw at him
get it
so all we need to do now is wait for
trakosaurus and the splashback spartan
to fight
who will win
[Music]
now for the biggest update in what feels
like forever
i was checking out our lord and savior
graham the gnome
and noticed a green beacon-like thing
attached to the rock face below
what could this be so i searched for
more clues
and lo and behold what is underneath the
waves
a crashed spaceship like a space pod and
somebody
is trapped inside
[Music]
get yourself into replay mode and get
your camera close enough and you can see
inside is a very detailed character
this guy must be important to the season
or maybe the storyline
expect to be click-baited hard by those
terrible youtubers over the next week
but on the plus side this opens up so
many possibilities
the green beacon looks to have attracted
a space vessel
and this will likely mean a new poi
which will grow from this point
maybe a space station maybe an alien
colony
i can't wait to find out but i have one
question above all others
did graham the gnome call in the space
adventurers
is this why graham is found at the radio
tower i always knew graham was the
mastermind behind battle royale loops
but now we have more evidence you guys
who like story theories now is your time
to flex in the comments
is area 69 coming to fortnite is it
sorry is area 51 coming to fortnite
my bad moving on
[Music]
now let's rock up to the crustaceans on
the island near the lighthouse
over the last few weeks those bouncy
inhabitants set up a basic settlement on
the beach
before being joined by pirate
adventurers last update
well this week they have joined the
stone age of evolution
becoming akin to the egyptian empire
with a freaking pyramid
that's impressive building skills maybe
we should get these guys to build hut
watch
so it's finished in less than two years
the settlement continues to evolve as
more villagers move in
these guys are here to stay and by the
looks of things
there's going to be a ton of them by the
end of season 3. in addition to these
crustaceans there are some secret ones
to be found
back on the original coral island there
was an impressive clam chest
well now the water is receding take a
look at it again because you'll notice
the egyptian crustaceans are beginning
to build something in stone
what do you think that could be also
also that's terrible i'm sorry can we
also take a second to check out the
pickaxes on these bad boys
these are the cutest little things in
history of fork knife i need one of
these
as a plush toy please anyway enjoy the
season my friends let's check back on
these rubber balls next update
this links into a secret riddle of the
sphinx achievement so if you want that
be sure to visit here but also
up at the lighthouse there is another
one and if you venture completely south
from there at the apex of the next
island
you'll get all three and that's an
achievement done and dusted
oh by the way whilst checking out the
pois i noticed the whirlpool is back
again
and here is how i found that out a
freaking shark was using it to pass the
time in game
look how happy he is so i joined in for
a while and we frolicked
together it was fun stayed awesome my
friend
okay that was terrible i need a better
shark pun all my jokes feel a little
sarcastic
but believe me i don't mean any sarcasm
sorry with vehicles almost here let's
note the gas and petrol station upgrades
this one in salty is impressive but
check out the beast
in lazy links this new fuel mechanic
must be hugely important to the season
oh and if you saw epic's update they
said no sweat insurance took away the
vehicles
well i thought this would mean the
return of the diorama inside their
headquarters
but nope still nothing here i'll keep
checking back
and let you know in fact while speaking
about no sweat insurance have you
noticed the no sweat storage building
has been terminated everything has gone
midas stolen chair
and the bear gnome puppet show lost to
the ether
just like the piranha island last week
and this continues everywhere as the
rubbish islands have faded away
as we wait for roads to join the island
back together
[Music]
a few smaller updates to note the pirate
galleon which was randomly moving around
each week has moved yet again
last week it looked certain to plough
into the dam
but this week nah it's changed its mind
completely
and turned the opposite direction i've
been trying to understand the
positioning here but i'll be honest
i have no idea what the ship is doing if
you do
i'll be in the comments looking for
direction help needed please
over at the authority the water levels
have dropped far enough to see the main
hatch open
will this be for vehicle access i guess
so but we need to wait a little bit
longer to be sure
but looking at this place now look how
cool it is it's like a real life
fortress
very epic epic as the water levels
continue to drop we can expect
absolute carnage in the buildings with
vehicles turned over and lots of seaweed
everywhere
and lots of items thrown around by the
water and by the looks of it
new points of interest are coming it's
an exciting time as we get closer to the
live event
and i wonder if it will be space themed
what do you reckon
and later this week it's fortnite's
birthday they are three already
don't they grow up so quickly and there
are rumors that penny from save the
world
may make it into battle royale this year
fingers crossed
if you made it this far hit me with team
thick let's get the good vibes going
before penny joins us in battle royale
so there we have it 20 updates in 10
minutes thank you very much for watching
what was your favorite update this week
and did i miss anything
on screen now are the legends roll call
those people who were kind enough to use
code adamara in the store
and dm me on twitter with a pic of
something they newly bought
i salute you and thank you
wholeheartedly i'm adam from playstation
grenade it's been a pleasure
i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bye